خلال الساعه الاولى من بدء صراع في
السودان كان قائد القوات المسلحه عبد
الفتاح البرهان في مواجهه مباشره كادت
تنهي حياته معلومات كشفتها وكاله رويترز
للمره الاولى تقول ان قوات الدعم السريع
اشتبكت مباشره مع البرهان وحراسه الشخصي
في مقر القياده العامه للجيش السوداني بعد
عمليه اقتحام شنها افراد من قوات الدعم
السريع على المبنى بحسب المعلومات التي
نقلتها رويترز عما وصفته بحارس شخصي
للفريق اول عبد الفتاح البرهان فان
الساعات الاولى كانت حاسمه في الصراع
وتسببت بمقتل العشرات وفقا لشهاده حارس
البرهان فان القوات المهاجمه قتلت 30
عنصرا من حراس البرهان واجبرت المواجهه
قائد الجيش على القتال بنفسه بواسطه
كلاشنكوف قبل ان ينقله حراسه الى مكان امن
لتنسحب قوات الدعم السريع من المكان عقب
الماليه العمليه الخاطفه كشفت عن الاسلوب
المفضل لخصم البرهان الفريق اول محمد
حمدان دقلو المعروف باسم حميثي وهو القتال
من مسافات قريبه واستغلال نقاط القوه لدى
قواته امر قد يفسر استمرار تمدرس قوات
الدعم السريع في عده مناطق بالعاصمه
السودانيه حتى اللحظه وغير هذا وذا قد
يفسر سبب تعنت كل من الخصمين في الحسم
العسكري فروايه الساعات الاولى تقول انها
بدات حاسمه وبنيه القتل رائد المصطفى
العربي لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات